the day today is an ominous March 13th
2020 why do I say ominous because it is
Friday the 13th but not to worry in this
video we're gonna remain alert not
anxious I'm not gonna give you any
number updates starting this video
because I think the numbers are horribly
inaccurate especially here in the United
States for one main reason we don't have
enough testing kits to find out who
actually has this virus but let's talk
about it you ready
the w-h-o has officially labeled this
virus a pandemic
not really surprising two videos ago we
said that it was technically a pandemic
then now we have this label on it what
does it mean for you practically
speaking not much it means that this
virus is internationally spreading it
can spread through countries very easily
there's more funding available more
communication happening between health
agencies but on a day-to-day standpoint
this pandemic label shouldn't really
affect you you may have noticed there's
closures happening cancellations
happening all across the board in fact I
had 5/6 speaking engagements get
postponed speaking at Johns Hopkins Yale
the college of new jersey all of these
have to take a backseat for public
safety now I know seeing all these
cancellations can get you worried but
we're gonna stay alert not anxious
cancellations are a good thing this is a
public health measure that actually
shows solidarity within our community
because when we shut down these events
we limit how this virus spreads why is
it important to limit this virus spread
because we have to offer community
protection to those who can't protect
themselves this means two elderly those
with serious medical chronic conditions
and those who are immunocompromised
possibly because of a medical condition
or medication they may be taking
traditionally we offer this type of herd
immunity or community protection through
vaccines unfortunately we cannot make a
vaccine this quickly and a w-h-o has
stated the earliest possible timeline
for this vaccine would happen mid 2021
so we can't expect the vaccine soon but
we are going to be talking about
possible treatments in the coming
minutes another reason I've talked about
on CNN of why it's important to limit
community spread because we do not want
a run on hospitals in Italy they're
experiencing a tremendous need for
equipment for doctors because their
hospitals are getting overrun with
patients who need respiratory support
who need fluids
and here in the United States we simply
do not have enough ICU beds if everyone
is to get this virus simultaneously so
by slowing the rate at which this virus
infects others we're doing something
called flattening the curve
traditionally when in a population of
individuals get sick there's a bell
curve that happens what we like to do is
to flatten this curve the way we do that
is by limiting crowded events here in
New York State we actually have a rule
no events with greater than 500
individuals we're probably gonna see
that tighten even further and I would
not be surprised to see schools shut
down because we want to flatten that
curve we want to decrease the spread so
that our hospitals can manage the
individuals who are sick and not run
into a problem like they have in Italy
many of my patients and friends have
been asking about what they can do to
protect themselves from this novel
coronavirus it's still personal
responsibility you have to not go out
when you're sick you have to limit your
exposure to large crowds while you may
have tickets for a show you want to see
or maybe your sporting event is still
going on try and limit that spread the
CDC put an urgent warning out to those
over the 60 I think that warning should
apply to more people and again it
doesn't mean we should be panicking this
isn't a panic Demick this is a pandemic
what we should be doing is staying alert
not anxious and the way we do that is by
getting quality information from sources
like the w-h-o and CDC so that we can be
best informed to protect our health and
the health of our family members in all
honesty I wanted to film this video
yesterday but I was working a 12-hour
Hospital shift seeing patients what did
I learn there's truly a scarcity of
supplies and 95 masks which are the
properly fit masks that we as health
professionals should be wearing to
decrease viral spread to surgical masks
those inexpensive masks you see on
social media we need our patients to
wear those so they don't get us sick and
finally and the most importantly testing
kids we need more testing kits we need
to be able to identify who has kovat 19
and who has another virus that's less
important in this given time without
testing kits we can't properly
quarantine people and we're obviously
corn seeding people that do not have
kovat 19 that's truly a problem so I
call on the white house coronavirus task
force get us the equipment we need on
the frontlines as health professionals
because the last thing we want to happen
is to have more doctors nurses CMAs PA
all of us on the front lines to get sick
and then not have anybody to take care
of our patients let's go ahead and jump
into the subject that I'm most
passionate about misinformation people
die from the flu and this is very
unusual and it is a little bit different
but in some ways it's easier and in some
ways it's a little bit tougher there are
some similarities between the flu and
kovat 19 but there are very serious
differences similarities they're both
viruses they both spread through
respiratory droplets the symptoms are
similar
however the severity is quite different
the lethality is quite different and
most importantly we do not have a
vaccine and we don't have an antiviral
medication fda-approved to treat kovat
19 what does all that mean it means the
last allottee rate is gonna be higher
more people are gonna lose their lives
because of Cova 19 than the flu more
people are gonna get infected with kovin
18 than the flu because it's more
infectious early research suggests this
virus can spread two to three times
faster than the influenza virus this is
why it's become a pandemic in a matter
of months there is a chain letter going
around titled information on corona
virus I can't believe I'm even saying
the term chain letter but it is going
around via email and Twitter I saw even
brother nature retweeted it and it has
like a hundred fourteen thousand
retweets on it it has quote unquote
Stanford notes on coronavirus Stanford
came out and did a public message said
they have nothing to do with this
because this misinformation is spreading
like wildfire some of the things written
in here drinking warm water is effective
for all viruses if you have a runny nose
and sputum you have a common cold it
talks about a ten-second breathing test
that if you're able to hold your breath
for 10 seconds you don't have the novel
coronavirus what none of this is
medically accurate and this goes to show
that just because a celebrity gets a lot
of retweets or likes on a given post it
does not mean it's accurate information
trust the CDC w-h-o or trust the health
professionals that are actually dealing
with this crisis head-on let's talk
about two pieces of misinformation that
I think even some medical experts have
gotten themselves confused over one is
about using certain supplements to help
prevent or treat the novel coronavirus
zinc being a primary example yes there
was a study that showed zinc interrupts
replication of this virus which is a
good
however very important if you actually
read the study it shows that the zinc
needed to be inside your actual cells
not just in your bloodstream or in your
stomach in the cells the way that the
researchers got the zinc into the cells
was through a zinc ionophore it's
basically like a little tunnel that
allowed the zinc to enter the cell then
it interfered with the viral replication
good stuff however taking a zinc lozenge
does not create a zinc gateway a zinc
ionophore to enter into our cells so no
taking zinc by mouth does not disrupt
the viral replication this is why we
need to be very careful when we read
research to actually read it not just
skim over the abstract next let's move
on to surface contamination how long
does the novel coronavirus live on
surfaces there's been some really good
research coming out in this area and the
range that we're seeing is from hours to
a day or two sometimes three days if we
see perfect temperature humidity and
surface conditions this virus does live
longer on plastic and steel surfaces
meaning non-porous ones so you want to
make sure to be wiping down commonly
used surfaces like keyboards like
faucets that's obviously very important
but the doctors that are going out there
and saying that it lasts one to two
weeks practically speaking especially
outdoors that's not true and in the one
study that came out and talked about
this nine-day period it was for a very
specific sub strain of this virus does
not apply to the majority of cases also
I'm gonna reiterate the primary driver
of how this virus spreads is through
respiratory droplets meaning that you
inhale them you touch your mouth eyes or
nose so surface contamination is a
possible way to spread it but the main
one is those aerosolized particles it
doesn't mean it's airborne because it's
not technically airborne it's
aerosolized particles that are
temporarily hanging in the air that's
what I call germ hang time that's why in
the winter time there's a higher chance
you get sick because the air is drier
more germs hanging in the air for a
longer period of time
easier to get sick the longest that
we've seen them hang around three hours
for this novel coronavirus so it is
possible to walk into a room that's
empty where someone sneezed before and
inhale some of these respiratory
droplets but outdoors that's not
something you should be
concern about because the Sun with its
UV rays is our most powerful
disinfectant let's move on and talk
about a common conspiracy question that
I've been getting asked did this virus
come out of a lab in China if conspiracy
theorists believe that this is a
bioterrorism weapon it's a really bad
one because it's crushed the Chinese
economy as well as the International
economy it has a very low lafalot II
rate for something that's considered to
be deadly if it escaped out of a lab in
China which we have no evidence for that
it does not change anything that we have
to do now to protect ourselves you want
to talk about after the fact once we're
investigating this virus cool but right
now we need to take actionable steps to
stay alert not anxious be educated and
protect ourselves and our family members
let's move on to potential treatments
because that's what I'm most optimistic
about there are well over 300 clinical
trials ongoing right now and that's a
good and bad thing bad because there's
some medications that shouldn't be
tested are and it's taking away from the
patient pool that can be enrolled in
these studies good because we're getting
a lot of different options tested all at
once
leading the way REM des aveer it's an
antiviral medication that was primarily
used to treat Ebola the way that it
works is interrupts the virus's
replication cycle let's think back how
does a virus work it infects your cell
then it hijacks the cells own inside
machinery and replicates itself we want
to stop that process to prevent the
virus from spreading
hopefully REM disappear does just that
other medications that we have being
tested HIV medications like Kell Terra
chloroquine which is an anti-malarial
medications all showing some initial
promise but we got to get those studies
in in fact the NIH has a study going on
in the US with from desi beer that's
scheduled to have some results by next
month I'm really excited to see those
because if we can decrease the
complication rate like pneumonia
secondary infections even death we can
make a huge impact for those suffering
with kovat 19 if you suspect that you
have kovat 19 or any virus for that
matter call ahead to your health
professionals practice before just
heading over it's really important in
fact here's what I want you to take away
from this video wash your hands wash
your hands wash your hands I'm gonna say
it again
stay home especially if you're sick
three avoid large crowds if at all
possible because that's how the virus
spreads
or try not to touch commonly touch
surfaces with your fingertips use your
elbow hip whatever you can instead 5
don't believe misinformation from
celebrities just because they get a lot
of likes or retweets only the CDC w-h-o
or other verified health professionals
and finally don't panic stay alert
not anxious so you can make the best
decisions for yourself and your family
members I put together a couple
playlists for you check them out right
here or right here I want to know which
you like better while you stay happy and
healthy
[Music]